folks coming out of that field down in
Virginia carrying swastikas and torches
and the veins and bulging on their skin
as they were screaming it was a wake-up
call for us as a country
and for me a call to action
at that moment I knew I'd have to run
because my father taught us that silence
was complicity
oh really by that standard the president
of the United States is complicit in
that antifa violence going on outside of
Atlanta where thugs have descended on a
new police training project
[Music]
no that wasn't Charlottesville that was
actually in Atlanta okay this is
domestic terrorism which the Georgia
Bureau of Investigation is charging
these 23 individuals with only two of
them though are actually from Georgia
with one being from Canada another from
France and even more outrageous yet kind
of unsurprising one of those charged is
an attorney for the Southern Poverty Law
Center the group that proclaims its
Mission as rooting out extremism
well it employs those that engage in
extremism
those facts especially Interstate travel
component what the heck is the excuse
for Biden and Garland not to move
forward at least discuss this how about
an indictment of these folks everyone
wants to give credit to Biden for coming
out against that D.C city council Bill
like you suddenly Mr tough guy on crime
but his silence here reveals the real
story joining us now is Stephen Miller
former senior advisor to president Trump
and founder of America First legal
Stephen I mean to listen to Merrick
Garland
it's white supremacy is rampant across
the country and that's the focus of what
they're going to prosecute and pursue
yet he also claims that without fear or
favor we go after all domestic terrorism
does that look like that's the case here
at least yet
no since the first day of this
Administration it's been The Narrative
of Joe Biden and the mayor garland that
white supremacists are roaming the whole
country terrorizing our citizens
destroying our cities and all the might
of the Department of Justice will be
used to pursue them but they don't
really mean white supremacists what they
really mean is targeting conservative
Americans targeting Republicans and of
course targeting Donald Trump we're now
in the third year of the doj's January 6
investigation and it will never end as
long as they are continuing to wield the
prosecutorial power but what is actually
happening in our country is you have
antifa rioters laying Siege to a police
training center and total Silence from
Joe Biden total Silence from doj not
just about this attack but about all the
antifa attacks and of course all the BLM
attacks or the Department of Justice was
dropping charges against BLM rioters in
case after case after case that were
initial initiated under the Trump
Administration
well current Jean Pierre was asked about
this situation today watch this
is the White House tracking this and how
worried is the White House about this no
I
we have not been I have not heard any
discussions about this protest over the
weekend so we'd have to go back to the
team and see where we are where we're
standing and and a response on that just
this is the first time I'm hearing on
about this protest over the weekend
it's the first time she's hearing about
it I mean if this was something that
happened at CPAC you know that was some
scuffle outside CPAC should be all over
it but oh no it's just a police training
site it's a giant protest where they're
swarming it over the weekend and setting
fire but that's so not I haven't gone
lovely a lovely peaceful polite
Gathering not anything like when they
said 30 armed officers to go into the
home of a pro-life activist and and
we've seen this again and again with the
Department of Justice uses extraordinary
force against conservative Americans or
pro-life Americans again while antifa is
running free and running wild not to
mention the drug cartels and the gang
members running absolutely a mock in
almost every major city in America our
children our teens are dying from
Fentanyl and you know they're asleep at
the switch Stephen thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else